you're about to find out that you've
been taking notes organizing your life
and planning events entirely wrong what
why because you haven't been using
notion
you've probably been storing your data
in various files trying to organize it
into folders but notion notion gives you
a completely new workspace really stick
around and you'll learn how an idea from
the 1960s by Information Technology
Pioneer Ted Nelson inspired a feature in
notion okay wait let's slow it down for
a second what's notion what's notion
what's notion notion is a tool that
allows you to document layout and format
anything from your personal ideas to
your secret goals to managing and
tracking your team projects notion is an
amazing app because it's a near Perfect
Blend of customizable and functional
which makes it akin to a canvas where
the user is the artist notion provides
the user with over 40 different blocks
available for representation of the
user's data in a large number of
different ways laying out planning and
organizing their life using blocks one
page at a time you can download notion
for free by using my link in the
description below wait what are pages I
hear you ask any block that exists with
a notion has to exist within a page
whether it's some simple text from an
email that you know you will need later
or a whole database now Pages can exist
within Pages which means that pages are
also blocks this moves notion away from
files and folders to just Pages which
adds a lot of fluidity to the way your
data can be stored pages are the
fundamental building block in notion
every complex page that you can create
in notion starts as a simple page at
first
you can create a new page simply by
clicking this button down here or by
typing slash page on any existing page
to create a nested page if your
hierarchy of pages ever gets too
complicated you can add a breadcrumb to
be able to navigate your pages easier
make sure to add an icon and a cover to
really give your page some personality
you can provide links to any image or
GIF on the Internet or upload your own
do you have a page that you keep coming
back to just add it to your favorites so
that it'll be at the top of your sidebar
notion can be used for many different
things
to say a notion is a note-taking app
would really not be doing it much
Justice at all but it's certainly
capable of that furthermore those of you
who are used to taking notes in a
markdown style notion supports most of
the syntax and copying and pasting
markdown notes carries across the
formatting do you have a big idea simply
type slash heading 1 or hash followed by
a space to give yourself a heading is
your idea not that big well you can
always take it down a notch by using
heading 2 or heading 3. do you have some
really important text that you want to
draw attention to add a call out change
the icon and boom now this text draws
attention to itself need some space like
whoa seriously give me some space no
problem add a divider to really separate
all the creeps from the normal text want
to hide everything under a heading
simply turn it into a toggle heading
instead and toggle away
oh and by the way you can click on most
blocks in notion to reformat it as
something else
in a book journaling your thoughts
perhaps are you tired of writing quotes
in quotation marks use the quote block
to give it a different look
are you sick of this invariable look do
you want to see some action well was
that multi-column layout simply drag a
block next to another block next to
another block next to another block
anyway get the idea this can be done
with anything to change the way your
notion page looks alternatively type
slash columns to see the options below
now there's no reason for your notes
ideas and dreams written down in Ocean
to look as boring as they do notion
actually provides a lot of customization
within the app anything from changing
the font size and style to text and
background color does your notion page
seem a little cramped no problem simply
make the page full width don't like the
font no problem simply choose another
like everywhere else
size of the font too small well who
turned small text on change it to a size
that you can read does this text look
boring to you no well it should change
the background color still boring how
about you try changing the foreground
color
perhaps this whole look just ain't your
style well you can try dark mode both
light mode and dark mode look great in
Ocean and you can easily switch between
them with Ctrl shift L ah lists we all
need them for various things in our life
whether it be a to-do list for the day
or a recipe that you want to write down
or a speech that you're preparing or
perhaps a summary that you're right out
of the case notion has you covered
notion also provides you with the
ability to make tables like word or
Google Docs so if you need to keep track
of something slash table to get yourself
a table no no no not that kind of table
now this this is a table
need more rows or columns simply click
these very intuitive plus buttons and
you'll get your rows and columns and
then just fill in your data databases
databases are used for storing and
presenting data there are many different
use cases for them from storing your
favorite movies or plans for your year
to progress boards for your team this
enables the user to be more creative and
organized and allows teams to use a
centralized app for both their creative
and organizational needs
table view can be used to keep your
classes organized or maybe you want to
keep track of which books you're reading
Board of view is a representation of
your data in kanban style this separates
your workload into cards with statuses
associated with different tasks boards
like these are often used for project
management
timeline view of a database can be used
to help with issue tracking as it
displays the dates associated with the
issues and can help a project manager
keep track of the team's progress and
workload calendar view lets you easily
see how database items connect to
certain dates list view is a simple and
minimalistic way of looking at a
database it's ideal for storing notes
articles and documents that don't need
too many properties gallery view is the
best way to display databases with
visual components like mood boards
office directories virtual recipe
Collections and so on
synced databases allow you to sync data
from other platforms into notion
databases
these include jira boards and projects
GitHub or gitlab pull requests and
issues or Asana projects and tasks every
database can be presented using the
views we've just covered and you can
always add more views to view your data
in a different way you can also name
your views when adding a view you can
choose a number of different settings
such as showing the title size of the
preview and how the page will open when
a user will click on it there are also a
bunch of other settings such as grouping
filters in databases and sorting Works
similarly to other apps that have these
features like Excel or Google Sheets
notion gives you a lot of control over
the way your data is presented
notion also allows you to save these
filters and sorting for everyone or just
for yourself which is the default notion
can also be used for team and project
management the views mentioned earlier
allow for high flexibility in terms of
creating work environments that suit any
team's needs whether you're into
software development design marketing or
sales whatever your area is notion can
certainly Aid you in becoming more
organized and efficient notion also
provides a bunch of other features that
allow for better team communication and
integration
for example you can tag team members in
relevant places instead of trying to
look through chains of messages or
emails notion also provides you with the
ability to comment on pages that way
people can give feedback on work
asynchronously and see what others think
at a glance
do you like Notions so much but you
aren't sure whether this is something
you want to use to take notes during
your Q3 meeting right next to your top
10 spring season anime list no problem
notion allows you to easily have
multiple workspaces along with different
accounts so you can have a personal
account which is for your eyes only and
a work account is this still not enough
are you really that busy that you want
to have a different workspaces under the
same account well you can do that too
have as many different workspaces for
all I care anything to help you be more
productive media this is something that
will be very useful for all the creative
individuals that have been missing a
centralized place to keep their thoughts
or their mood and vision boards
create mood boards easily notion can
automatically embed your images using a
link or via file upload
do you have a favorite webpage that you
like to check every day like the weather
or the news or flight prices just create
a home page so that you don't have to
waste time checking these sites by
opening your browser every day do you
have some favorite videos that just make
you laugh sometimes and you'd like to
store them all in one place just embed
them and organize them however you like
within your notion pages what about a
favorite song or remix or some audio
recordings that's part of something
you're working on you can nicely embed
them in notion pages so they don't get
lost you can use code segments to
demonstrate code conventions in a
software project or use it for a more
intuitive explanation of code as a
software engineering team we use this a
lot you can also easily attach files to
pages and annotate them
there are lots of applications that
integrate nicely with notion that can
enhance your workflow whether it will be
a document from Google Drive or a tweet
from your favorite online personality or
a gist from GitHub favorite location
from Google Maps anyway here's a
complete list of them so if you want to
use a platform that's missing from here
maybe it's in the works notion supports
rendering graphs using mermaid which you
can use to display your ideas visually
this is much easier to iterate over than
simply using an image template buttons
allowed the user to easily create
complex designs within notion quite
literally with the click of a button to
prevent you from having to spend time
copying and pasting and formatting the
page to make it look nice just make it
once and template away the table of
contents is a nice way to provide an
overview of the entire document so it's
easier to navigate
block equation on any notion page you
can display beautifully formatted
comprehensive mathematical characters
expressions and equations like in latex
this comes in handy for note-taking
technical documentation homework or
anywhere you need to use math thanks
block are you working with an idea
that's constantly changing instead of
updating all the places where it's
mentioned manually just use a synced
block this is an idea that is largely
called transclusion from the information
technology Pioneer Ted Nelson in his
hypertext model founded in 1960.
transclusion means that part of one
thing is included in another and brought
from the original this is what gave rise
to this synced blocks feature text that
could live and breathe in multiple
places with any edits reflecting
everywhere it's used are you ready to
make the switch to notion are you
hesitating because you're already really
organized in a different app or platform
or maybe you just have a lot of
documents to bring together and perhaps
you're not exactly psyched for the whole
importing of all this data well you may
be in luck since notion allows for an
easy import from supported formats and
will handle the bulk of the formatting
for you for example here's a Google doc
imported into notion now all of these
features might sound overwhelming but
don't worry about having to set
everything up yourself notion provides
hundreds of templates available on their
website and within the app a are you a
student that likes to take notes for
class on their laptop take this template
for example doesn't it make you want to
go to your next class and take some
notes that's what organizational apps
should do or maybe you're a busy
professional that has a lot of meetings
to go to take this template for example
or this one here
if you have an idea for how you want to
use notion then chances are there's a
template out there to make the process
quicker and easier
now it's possible to do many more things
in notion with additional plugins and
workarounds there are lots of crime
extensions available and so many
embeddable widgets on option.co that can
really personalize and customize your
notion
for example you can use the Pomodoro
Timer widget to keep your study notes
and timer in one place without needing
to check your phone and getting
distracted or check out this really cool
flip clock that I found doesn't that
make you just want to stare at the
switch of every minute
huge thank you to Notions for creating
this amazing app and sponsoring this
video without them note taking
organization planning wouldn't be as
much of a joy as they are and have been
over the years of using their app go
ahead and download notion and try it out
for yourselves using my link in
description below thanks for watching
and I'll see you guys next time goodbye